What law school were easy?
What if law school were fun?
What if law school DIDN'T SUCK?
Every year, college students from around the country come to
law school to play game they've never
seen where no one gives them the rules.
Unfortunately what worked in college
doesn't work in law school law school.
Law school is graded on a curve you so are fighting
everybody else for the top spot
You don't just have to be good, you have
to be better than the rest.
Law school can seem overwhelming.  It seems like there is
an infinite amount of work and
impossibly small amount of time
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
But law school doesn't have to be hard.
when you know the rules, the goals, and
strategies everything changes.
Law school can be broken down.  The system can be gamed.
When you know what to do, it all
seem so effortless
Welcome to Legal Eagle.  With Legal Eagle
you'll learn time-tested strategies to
help crush law school exams and make law
school easy.  Work smarter not harder.
Learn how to crush law school with Legal Eagle
You can do this!
With Legal Eagle